good options
the story of Puss in Boots Last Wish is
essentially a story of a superhero who
discovers his vulnerability and that's
what boots is missing in his life
so all of us who are working on this
movie took our own experiences of
feeling fear feeling anxiety feeling
weak and said how can we kind of push
put some boots into this corner his flaw
is that he's not willing to lower his
Legend to be vulnerable and make these
meaningful connections with people so
panic attack evolved as a necessity for
us to force him to be vulnerable it
wasn't like we started with the idea of
puss having a panic attack it's sort of
nearly naturally occurred when we were
trying to say how do we show House good
pusses but
what
but the first time we assembled the film
there was no panic attack and it's
always a tricky balance when you're
trying to make a movie that you want for
the most part to be as much fun and
funny and as exciting as possible to
suddenly have this very kind of scary
tense moment he's always got the shield
up that's projecting invincibility until
his fear his anxiety push him into this
corner where he drops that Shield which
opened him up for perito to come in and
show him what a connection can be we
knew we had to work towards a moment
where you could really feel the stakes
of how that experience impacts him that
along with the character Arc of burrito
we know we wanted a moment to of like
him showing that he actually is a good
therapy dog and a good friend you know
we're just come out of a really
action-packed sequence with a lot of
color a lot of vibrancy and we wanted to
really bring the world down Center it
really just around puss changing the
palette thinning out the environment
dropping the focus going into that space
where it was it was really just kind of
almost blurry around everything except
for him and almost feel like the entire
environment changed based off of his own
emotional experience he can't see
straight he can't hear and then the only
thing he has left is a sense of touch
there's no math to it you have to feel
it and when that head rests on puss's
stomach
it just felt like that's it that's the
moment that's turning this scene
I think there's always a little bit of
back and forth in between what maybe a a
human would do in a frame to do that
specific action and also kind of look at
how a dog would approach it
foreign
was like Hey you know my dog does
exactly that like it's exactly the same
way so there's a lot of study that goes
into like how a dog would actually just
rest his head on your belly when when
you're maybe feeling down or maybe just
they just want to you know just finding
that right mechanics that right like
intention from an animal perspective but
also kind of get the the human or or
more emotional aspect of it it makes me
cry when I watch the scene because it's
just it's born out of this moment of
helplessness and love and prito just
really wants to help and that's all he
can think of to do but it's so powerful
like it it calms pushed down it brings
him out of his panic attack and then
he's able to open up to dog about what's
really bothering him and and Frito
becomes a real therapy dog there because
puss is you know confessing to him about
what's going on just something he would
never do before I think that's what
excited us too where in a movie that is
so high octane and hilarious as it
should be for a family film we knew that
to have a serious poignant moment that's
very real between two characters would
stand out as an emotional set piece that
you could feel and appreciate when the
movie slows down to this point because
it's that moment where it is the first
time you see him die way there's a
little bit more creative Liberties there
we have access to Antonio recording the
dialogue so we can get a lot from his
performance combining all of these to
make the most believable performance
possible on screen Antonio's performance
was fantastic it was actually difficult
sometimes choosing the takes and as well
with Harvey you know he's bringing a
great deal of Comedy but he really
leaned into the warmth and the sweetness
and the caring for plus and you can feel
it in his performance you feel how much
prito loves Plus
oh
thank you perito
what's going on with you plus
I am down to my last life so there were
early versions that felt kind of jokey
post was talking the whole time and he
would say everything he was feeling and
it just didn't feel right and then even
when we got the first pass of the script
I felt like there was still too many
words like can we tell this story
without dialogue and just really feel
what they're feeling see what they're
seeing hear what they're hearing and
just play it with sincerity as a writer
you know one of the last things you're
going to think of is like less talking
but uh it was a good scene it was
dramatic but it just wasn't quite
landing and feeling authentic and then
at some point the idea came up like
let's just try less here losing a lot of
the dialogue and I knew it was going to
work when I saw those storyboards
because you know I was feeling it in the
moment as Taylor was like pitching the
scene I thought this works better than
any written version and of course it
does it's animation it's pantomime
animation does that better than anything
else you already have to nail everything
you have to nail the expression you have
to nail that feeling you have to nail
that heartbeat you have to nail when do
you calm down right when do you come out
of that Panic to be able to kind of
start to to talk about the problem you
should tell Kitty she was no no no no
she cannot hears okay we want to create
this full spectrum of emotion of what
life can be you can laugh you can cry
you can be afraid and so when it came
time for this panic attack we knew it
had to be authentic we knew it had to be
genuine and not shy away from the real
feelings all of us as human beings have
it's just it takes your breath away as
one of the filmmakers to see that come
to life and to see since the films come
out to see the way people are discussing
it and how you know people have felt
that you know some people have said it's
the most realistic portrayal of a panic
attack all we had to do was stay true to
us and and I feel like the story tells
you what it wants it to be and it was
the first time I've ever heard an
audience like audibly you know react to
an emotional moment like that where the
whole theater was just like oh so I'm
getting emotional thinking about it
right now because for people to
understand like the story and the
message you're telling that's everything
and when someone tells you that your
voice and your sensibility is
emotionally resonating with them yeah
it's just uh it's exactly what why we do
this I think animated movies are
everyone movies or at least Puss in
Boots we wanted to make it for everyone
and I think the experience of this panic
attack it's something that happens to a
lot of people and it's treated with
sincerity even though it's an animated
movie and this is a cat and a dog we're
talking about it's something that they
can actually relate to I knew the moment
worked when we watched the movie as a
whole but seeing how it is emotionally
touched people and hearing their
responses that's really gratifying Maybe
you should tell that to Kitty
feel better
feel better too